[Music]
hey guys welcome to their installments
of Harry Potter theory in this video
were going to be discussing the ugly
cousin of the Dementor the left the fold
in Harry Potter there really isn't a lot
of information provided to us on life of
faults however if you know about
Dementors then you're already half of
the way to understanding what a letter
fold is as we know Dementors are cloak
creatures that had three meters tall
with dark gray scabby skin they are
truly foul and represent unhappiness and
despair originally created by JK Rowling
as a way of representing depression they
have the guards of Azkaban prison and
they're responsible for ensuring that
all of the darkest which isn't wizard
inside of the prison stay put the only
known defense against a Dementor is
expected patronum and in the books and
films harry is quick to learn the
Patronus charm because of his frequent
run-ins with these dark reaches expected
patronum evokes a positive energy force
known as a Patronus which is -
considered to be the spirit guardian of
the caster the Patronus represents hope
happiness survival and purity as the
Patronus does not feel despair or
hopelessness as a human might the
Dementors can't hurt it and they're
repelled by its presence however what is
particularly interesting about expecto
patronum is that it is also used to ward
off leather folds I feel that this truly
speaks to the dark nature of leather
folds if they're compared to Dementors
at all then they've got to be pretty
awful
we know that the Patronus charm is
effective against life the folds because
in 1752 wizard favia spell be used to
Patronus to ward off all of the fold
during an attack and like Dementors it's
the only known defense against them
Flavia spell be described the attack as
follows
it resembled nothing so much as a
rippling black cape the edges fluttering
slightly as it slithered up the bed
towards me
creepy fantastic beasts and where to
find them describes that the vaults as
follows the letter fault resembles a
black cloak roughly half an inch thick
and appears slightly thicker if the
creature has recently digested a victim
it glides along surfaces in an unknown
form of locomotion in search of its prey
humans it attacks at night when the
target is asleep by suffocating and then
digesting it by the sounds of it the
leather fold is dare I say it
fine than a Dementor it preys on humans
at night it's just as difficult to ward
off it sounds like it has its own agenda
entirely consume as many humans as
possible the etymology behind the name
Latha fold is quite sinister as leather
fault comes from two roots Leatham
variation of leta m-- which is Latin for
death annihilation and ruin as well as
fold which likely alludes to the
creatures cloaked appearance the leather
fold is a truly truly highly dangerous
magical beasts they are extremely
aggressive violent and even carnivorous
though extremely similar to Dementors
they do differ in that they are
classified by the Ministry of Magic as a
category xxxxX creature the
classification reserved for wizard
killers that are impossible to train or
domesticate Dementors are just
classified as non beings additionally
let the bulbs eat their victims where
Dementors just suck out their soul and
let the facade nonhumanoid while
demented are humanoid meaning that
wizards have been able to communicate
with Dementors
luckily the left fold is found only in
tropical climates so as long as you
don't go on holiday you should be safe
from them and that's it for this video
if you enjoyed it please be sure to like
the video and subscribe to the channel
do you want more videos on dark and evil
beasts let me know down in the comments
section below and until next time you're
a wizard Harry
[Music]